I had the good fortune and immense joy
of meeting Charles Burnett in person
over a decade ago at the pan African
Film Festival here in Los Angeles I'd
met him years earlier within the frames
of his work of course and felt connected
to this artist who relished sharing the
inner lives of working-class
african-americans on screen in all our
complexity his characters and stories
weren't flat they had round edges and
dimension with Charles my family my
community so often forgotten and
dismissed and ignored felt expansive and
robust and revered so when I met him at
that beautiful black Film Festival with
my very first documentary in 2008 I
wrote in my journal that that night what
how can I look at it and I wrote he was
gentle and generous and full of grace
I met a giant today and he was he
watched my film my not very good film
twice and gave me feedback and kindness
and encouragement and that was like fuel
to me like water for the first time a
major artist to look at my work and say
you have something to say something
valuable to put out in the world in that
moment he made me visible to myself in a
world of visual culture visibility
remains highly political in a much
contested concept that touches upon
issues of identity and representation
ethics and responsibility recognition
and justice Charles Burnett has made the
black community visible and he has been
visible to the black community sir
you've been a giant to us a legend to us
an icon long before today to work to
create to craft your films with no
promise of industry consideration
support or recognition for decades upon
decades is the mark of a true artist
[Applause]
too many times in cinema history books
of which I have many I go to the page to
read about black cinema and so often
it's a paragraph a caption often a still
image with one film that's strong out of
the black cinematic canon to represent
everything that's been done by everyone
and very often it's killer of sheep just
a caption underneath if you're lucky
you'll get a paragraph or two I just
want to let you know mr. Burnett that to
us within the world of that paragraph
you are the universe you're one of the
most significant American directors in
cinema history of any color period your
masterful attention to style your use of
folkloric traditions in your engagement
with the social and political world
around us has centered blackness and
rendered us visible and valuable and
victorious and for that I thank you sir
tonight tonight I am pleased an honor to
salute you Charles Burnett on behalf of
the governors and present you with an
Academy Award